brice hortefeux est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir monsieur ce feu merci
d'être avec nous au député européen vice
président ump ancien ministre de nicolas
sarkozy 1er des sarkozystes peut-être
même entonné que la président de
l'association des amis de l'ancien chef
de l'état
suzette bloch de l' agence france-presse
et puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
nous rejoindrons tour à tour au cours de
cette émission réalisée également en
partenariat avec dailymotion
l'attentât contre l'ambassade de france
à tripoli d'abord avec deux gendarmes
français blessé une action hors de nos
frontières dans un pic est plongée dans
la sécurité avec l'action dès des
milices dans ce pays
néanmoins selon vous quelle était
ministre de l'intérieur brice hortefeux
est ce qu'il ya des leçons à tirer en
matière de terrorisme en france ont
d'abord vis-à-vis de la libye
la situation est évidemment un peu
particulier parce que la france y joue
un rôle majeur un jaune un rôle
essentiel elle a été à la pointe du
combat pour mettre fin au régime qui
était en place au régime du colonel
kadhafi elle était avec l'angleterre
avec le royaume uni
un des deux pays qui ont contribué à
rétablir la démocratie et sur ce
territoire donc naturellement c'est une
situation particulière deuxième élément
oui bien sûr la menace terroriste elle
existe elle est constante elle est
permanente et il faut pas oublier que
par exemple à l'époque où j'ai exercé
photo miss de l'intérieur et pendant le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy la direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur des
jouets en moyenne c'est une moyenne bien
sur presque deux attentats par an donc
c'est quelque chose qui est prégnant
nous avons la chance certainement
d'avoir parmi les services les plus
performants au monde qu'elles sont
perçues comme telles mais ça n'élimine
pas naturellement toutes les menaces
alors le terrorisme a évolué il ya le
terrorisme international le terrorisme
domestique et le théorise de réseaux il
terrorisme individuel tout ceci
naturellement à des choses plus
complexes très capable de critiquer mais
sur le plan de la sécurité intérieure
ont ni rien
il ya une continuité bien sûr de santé
c'est un sujet qui nécessite
naturellement une très grande cohésion
est donc là dessus je soutiens
pleinement l'action des services de
renseignements sur ce sujet voté
définitivement par l'assemblée nationale
et européenne
cette mesure 14 normales on se dit que
c'est une marche vers l'égalité qui
était inéluctable et qu'il n'y aura pas
de retour en arrière
oui bon ordre les données que vous venez
de rappeler son sont justes je vais pas
tout à fait le même jeu concernant le
plan européen ce qu'avait six pays qui
ont complètement adopté de certains noms
qui sont en cours de discussion
aujourd'hui s'il ya une minorité pays
européens qui rend compte qu'ils ont
adoptés minorité très très
exceptionnelle minorité dans le monde je
regrette que ce débat ait eu lieu dans
ces conditions c'était un texte qui à
mon avis était mal préparé un débat
tronqué avec un coup de force
parlementaire est aussi je le pense
sincèrement je dois éviter de polémiquer
sur ce sujet mais une forme de mépris
mépris vis-à-vis dès religions toutes
les religions monothéistes de notre pays
qu'elles soient catholiques juives
musulmanes ont condamné les toiles qui
attendait mais précisément ont condamné
cette ce projet précisément vous avez
raison de souligner parce que le mariage
est à la fois une institution civile
mais c'est le même mot qui est utilisé
pour la relier par les religions est en
tout cas par la région catholique donc
il ya une ambiguïté c'est celle que vous
soulevez et puis en même temps je trouve
qu'il ya eu un peu de mépris face aux
centaines et centaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont descendus dans la rue
des familles à l'évidence pour la
première fois qu'ils ont se sont engagés
pour des valeurs
les propositions de france à le faire
écouter je suis pas sûr honnêtement que
la réélection françois ahlonsou est due
exclusivement à 7 à cette initiative
il ya un point si vous voulez que je
crois trouve positive d'ailleurs que ce
soit françois pour ou contre c'est que
il ya eu des mouvements de population
des manifestations qui j'ai été un temps
ministre du travail
il ya eu des manifestations importantes
qui s'était déroulée pendant cette
période c'est ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
méprisable pour autant mais c'étaient
des revendications qui était de rands
ication matériel et catégorielles et là
il y a eu des manifestants un peu pour
beaucoup contre mais qui se sont engagés
sur des valeurs pour des valeurs on
pense à je pense que ces gens là et je
pense que c'est réconfortant et estimé
que ces militants vêtus en effet lors de
la manif pour tous peuvent être d'avoir
une place par exemple ma conviction
c'est qu'une partie de ceux qui se sont
déplacés qui est pour l'instant je vous
réponds bien sûr se sont déplacés pour
la première fois je pense que cet
engagement cet engagement collectif cet
engagement pour des valeurs un grand nom
en tout cas je l'espère voulons
poursuivre et dans cet engagement est
naturellement l'ump qui a vocation à
être la grande famille de rassemblement
de la droite et du centre c'est sa
vocation l'ump est bien est sans doute
la mieux à même d'accueillir et de
répondre à ces aspirations est-ce que
vous conseillez continuer à manifester
dans la rue alors que oui l'expression
ténue et dans l'expression naturelle
monte populaire va pas s'arrêter
j un rendez-vous qui est un rendez vous
important le 26 mai peut-être d'ailleurs
que la loi aura été examiné par le
conseil constitutionnel je sais pas ça
sans doute à quelques zéros à quelques
jours près mais moi je suis en tout cas
pour qu'il y ait une expression afin de
défendre une politique familiale avec
elle
sur la presqu'île à 1006 d'avoir marqué
ces hollande aux dictatures c'est ce
qu'on entend ça sera pour ceux qui
souhaiteront y participer mais je
respecte ceux qui nous ne serons pas
mais en tout cas ceux qui souhaiteront y
participer ce sera l'occasion d'exprimer
un sentiment pour une politique
familiale c'est politique familiale est
aujourd'hui remise en cause sur bien des
aspects notamment les aspects fiscaux
sociaux et autres
et peut-être que d'autres voudront
exprimer aussi une certaine forme de
lassitude vis-à-vis du pouvoir parce que
c'est vrai je constate certainement
comme vous vous en avez l'écologie pas
cool partager mais vous en avez des
cocons est passé d'une forme de désamour
on est aujourd'hui et aussi des on a
aussi dépassé le désaveu est que moi je
sens qu'il y ait une forme de colère que
finalement les sentiments républicains
qui sont indispensables dans une
démocratie est bien puis s'est exprimé à
cette occasion sa me semble pas
sentiments sont les sentiments
républicains parce que dans une
démocratie il faut une opposition à une
majorité que l'opposition s'exprime
qu'elle s'exprime au parlement qu'elle
s'exprime dans les médias et puis
qu'elle s'exprime aussi parfois dans la
rue c'est pas choquant je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait une sensibilité
dans notre pays quand on va dans la rue
c'est formidable à gauche quand on est
dans la rue c'est exceptionnel c'est
naturel soudain fait normal ce serait
absolument scandaleux que ce soit la
grande famille avec d'autres et bien au
delà de notre grande famille de droite
et du sang qui soient dans la rue ce
serait absolument inadmissible il faut
pas qu'il y ait deux poids deux mesures
dans une démocratie très fortement lors
des questions d'actualité on répondra
députés ump en disant cette démagogie ça
suffit et une critique la droite de
remettre en cause
l'inter d'euros à la suite de ces
attaques sur la légitimité du pouvoir
écoutez si si c'est une attaque de
l'état de droit de dire que l'on n'est
pas forcément d'accord avec tout ce que
fait la majorité c'est évidemment c'est
une conception assez extensive non je
suis désolé on n'est pas forcé d'être
d'accord ici une encore une fois je le
pense je le dit en souriant mais je
viens étant sur le fond dans une
démocratie moderne dit m
et qu'il doit y avoir une majorité qui
gouverne c'est le cas je partage pas la
manière dont elles gouvernent la manière
je ne partage pas ces moyens je ne
partage pas ses objectifs et il faut
qu'il y ait aussi une opposition qui
soit une opposition crédible unis
constructive
capable aussi de proposer et bien je
suis heureux participé aujourd'hui à
cette opposition qui notamment avec
l'ump s'exprime est ce que je pourrais
s'y faire aujourd'hui pour contester ça
mais j'étais né t il personne ne
conteste la légitimité ils ont ils ont
été élus françois hollande a été élu
chacun chacun de ses slogans
moi j'ai un truc à j ce rêve afin de
manifester pour défendre la politique
famille vous poser une question précise
est ce que j'irai manifester la réponse
est oui sur quel thème je vais pour
défendre une politique familiale vous
procurer beaucoup plus large
écoutez je souffre assez pas totalement
totalement éloignée quand m jid pour une
politique familiale est ce que selon
vous quand même la force que donne la
5ème république au chef de l'état me
permets est bien de surmonter cette
impopularité en d'autres termes est ce
que vous estimez quand même qu'il n'a
pas totalement les mains eméyé par cette
popularité en d'autres termes vous poser
la question si une différence entre les
4e et 5e liquid bas bien sûr sur
catherine répulsive gouvernement en
moyenne tous les six mois la durée 12
ans tous les 6 mois statistiquement il y
avait donc un nouveau gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous avons la démonstration
à l'évidence que nos institutions les
institutions fondées par général de
gaulle qui était un teyssen ce pirate
heures notamment qu'elle se reconnaît ma
famille politique et institution fondée
par le général de gaulle sont
extraordinairement solide parce qu'on
sait bien que si ça avait été un autre
régime à l'évidence il n'y aura plus
gouvernement françois fillon déclare que
tout ça pourrait mal finir est-ce que
vous penser la même chose ressort très
fun oui c'est ce que je vous dis on est
passé d'une forme de
et
d'indifférence au désamour et du
désamour des aveux et après le désaveu
je sens je sens qu'il ya une forme de
colère tout on sait cela mais apprécié
non mais précis après il y aura un
rendez vous avec les urnes je ne sais
pas quand au plus tard en tout cas en
2010 cette tour pour les élections
nationales et sans doute avant avec les
élections intermédiaires et bien non
pour le lancement à les français
s'exprimeront et diront ce qu'ils en
pensent est ce qu'il ya une différence
de nature montée avait effectué
l'antisarkozysme entre cette période là
ces attaques contre le chef de l'état
qui avec vos proches
et puis l'anti hollandisme le holland
bashing et nourrit aussi la presse la
gamme et rend fou le dis sans esprit
polémique c'est vrai qu'il y a à l'égard
des pouvoirs et ils nous prennent ce
soir quel qu'il soit une pression très
tendue mais je pense que les critères et
deux de mes gamins de mécontentement ne
sont pas les mêmes et aujourd'hui et il
emploie aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sens que le ce que l'on
perçoit très plus largement en dehors
des initiatives des politiques comme ça
c'est qu'il n'y a ni chef ni cap et je
pense que c'est pas vrai exactement
leurs proches que l'on pouvait faire un
nicolas sarkozy on va parler de la
situation de recours de nicolas sarkozy
est portée par les sondages quand on
évoque un instant est ce que vous
regrettez d'ailleurs prise amèrement la
défaite présidentielle vraiment quand on
s'engage moi je pensais avec quasiment
un français sur deux d'ailleurs que
nicolas sarkozy était le mieux à même
pour faire 1 face à cette crise majeure
la plus importante que nous ayons
rencontrée et affronter depuis 1929
quand je le pensais il y près d'un
français sur deux points le pensait 48
et demi pour cent des français mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que si vous faisiez
allusion aux enquêtes d'opinion vous
avez une enquête d'opinion assez
intéressante qui est paru il ya quelques
temps on a interrogé les français sur
qui le parmi les présidents de la
république y auraient fait mieux et vous
aviez nicolas sarkozy qui arrivait juste
après le général de gaulle et peut-être
noté donc c'est une forme aussi de
reconnaissance
la citation de nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui décidé finalement de jeter
l'épongé face à nathalie kosciusko
morizet la candidate des médias et du
système dit elle est ce que vous
comprenez sa décision et j'ai pas
compris de qui elle parlait comme
peignait des médias elle n'aime pas que
rachida dati était particulièrement
sevré de médias jouent pas un pas j'ai
pas perçu sa loge à écouter marché à
dati avait dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'elle avait des convictions un projet
fort pour paris et elle a indiqué m sur
une station de radio qu'elle irait
jusqu'au bout
donc je m'aperçois qu'elle prit la
décision exactement inverse elle doit
avoir des raisons je n'ai pas commenter
on ne comprenait les analyser je ne
commente pas est ce qu'elle a fait mais
est-ce qu'elle torpille même le
processus des primaires ump à paris
j'écoutais j'en sais pas je n'en sais
rien sur les primaires c'est une
décision de la fédération de paris ce
que ce dont je suis sûr en revanche
c'est sensuel et médiatique sur la
mesure
c'est d'adapter bien sûr et simplement
ce que je souhaite c'est que au delà de
j'allais dire de la primaire il y est
l'élection elle même et qui intéresse et
qui mobilise et moi je pense depuis
longtemps et c'est à l'évidence
aujourd'hui le cas puisque si une
candidate s'est retirée c'est qu'elle
pense qu'il y en a eu quelques bons
coups le quai meilleur et je suis
convaincu que nathalie kosciusko morizet
à la fois les qualités de compétences
d'intelligence de dynamisme des coûts de
la population de sobriété parfois de
discrétion qui seront autant d'atouts
pour paris un procès dans l'avion que
rachida dati n'a pas voulu affronter son
échec
écoutez si vous le dites pose la
question et bien si vous posez là que
sur un seul apporter la réponse ouvert
le chantier de la rénovation avec donc
la question
la primaire pour la présidentielle
françois molins après s'être déchiré
pour la présidence de l'ump voilà que
les ténors du parti s'écharpent sur les
primaires de 2017
d'un côté françois fillon et ses
lieutenants qui veulent des primaires
ouvertes pour l'élection présidentielle
on ne peut pas avoir une dichotomie dans
notre système politique où la gauche
ferait des primaires et l'ump n'en ferai
pas à partir du moment où je pense nous
allons en commun
j'ai pas entendu beaucoup d'oppositions
jusqu alors décidé de primaire c'est ça
qui est important après comment on les
organisera surtout qui sera candidat à
ces primaires c'est une autre question
al'inverse les primaires les copistes
n'en veulent pas le système actuel où le
président de l'ump est le candidat
naturel du parti leur convient tout à
fait lorsque l'on évoque ces histoires
de vote
le clan copé botton touche
les blu ray nous ce soir
et c'est également la position de
nicolas sarkozy pour qui si l'on en
croit son porte parole officieux brice
hortefeux les primaires sont secondaires
ils en acceptent donc l'idée mais croit
pouvoir sont dispensés c'est ce que
rapportent les journalistes bruno jeudy
et carole barjon dans le livre le coup
monté il faut se souvenir que nicolas
sarkozy était contre les primaires
organisées par le parti socialiste n'est
pas non plus un fan des ans des
élections internes dans son parti mais
il se rend compte que ce ne sera pas un
obstacle à son retour s'il décide de
revenir
il fera pas ça par la case partisane
c'est par la case parti qui
l'intéressent à il reviendra directement
en tant qu'ancien président en tant que
sauveur entre guillemets c'est la figure
du sauveur qu'on adore dans la vème
république
encore faut-il que les deux camps au
sein de l'ump s'entendent déjà sur le
principe d'une primaire pour l'instant
il ne s'accorde que sur un point la date
limite des débats à la fin du mois de
mai question alors nicolas sarkozy une
unique recours précise et non un peu
quelles seraient les conditions de ce
retour politique
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est un repère
c'est un repère parce que les enquêtes
d'opinion et vont toute violence en
feront tout elles vont toutes dans le
même sens et j'en ai recensé cesse
consécutive qui disait à peu près une
chose que distinguera très rapidement à
dix premiers éléments que c'est la
personnalité politique française qui
toutes sensibilités confondues pour pour
laquelle toutes sensibilités confondues
on souhaite la neige un rôle plus
important dans l'avenir toute
sensibilité droite gauche confondues
deuxièmement c'est est la personnalité
qui est considéré comme plus efficace
que françois hollande et certains même
d'ailleurs soul et est noté 3 x 3 x chez
les jours et trois fois plus efficace
perçu comme trois fois plus efficace
chez les ouvriers et 3e et éléments
c'est f comme je l'indiquais une
personnalité qui aujourd'hui est un
repère pour les lecteurs les électeurs
de droite et du sommaire
moi j'ai je ne parle pas de retour vous
poser la question sur leur cour je vous
dis aujourd'hui c'est un repère et mais
après la politique pour nicolas sarkozy
comme pour tout un chacun c'est une
question d' envie de devoir et
circonstances et donc je ne peux pas
répondre à ces questions toujours tout
cas mon avis aucun des trois critères
est aujourd'hui réalité vous avez
environ personnellement avant d'évoquer
les interrogations moi je souhaite
naturellement comme responsable de
l'association 2 et nicolas sarkozy que
l'on puisse être totalement engagé à ses
côtés de manière à ce que qu'il a ce
qu'il a accompli pendant le quinquennat
c'est un quinquennat extraordinairement
difficile face à la crise mondiale pris
de plein fouet
et bien ça c'est à ça soit une référence
donc nous dresser ce n'est pas une
question de nostalgie comprenez-moi bien
n'y a pas de nostalgie c'est une
confiance pour le présent et pour la
même coque comment vous voyez les choses
comment est ce que il arriverait bois
avec
il ya le cadre de la 5ème république
donc avec la cie si l'arrivée ce que
vous souhaitez donc avec la majesté
conférée par la vème république serait
le seul candidat de la droite pourrait y
avoir une autre vie mais là où et
m'entraîner sur un terrain qui n'est
absolument pas celui d'aujourd'hui
vous me posez la question d'anticiper
ses auteurs écoutez moi je vous dis je
mais attendez aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy c'est très simple et ne
se mêle pas de vie politique coty ne
s'en mêle pas c'est pas dire qu'il est
en dehors de la société il est
naturellement attentif à ce qui se passe
dans la société il le comprend ce que
ressentent les français ils partagent
leurs inquiétudes il reçoit les messages
qui lui sont adressés on évoquait vous
évoquez ces enquêtes d'opinion
effectivement qui sont très positives à
son égard mais aujourd'hui il les reçoit
comme autant de signaux affectif mais
qui n'entraîne pas de conséquences
politiques subjectif on peut
s'interroger sur les circonstances que
vous évoquez au même prix on trouve
qu'elles seraient les circonstances de
ce retour si c'est pas un critère
numérique si vous avez bien l'écouter ce
que je vous ai indiqué la politique
c'est une affaire dans vie de devoir
d'accord mais c'est une notion trop
étroit une situation politique
compliquée jp your des difficultés mais
encore une fois je ne me place pas sur
ce terrain ne vous ne pourrez pas me
faire dire que nicolas sarkozy a une
envie de revenir en politique je vous
dis aujourd'hui c'est un français parmi
les français et il ne se mêle pas de la
ville en fait d'utile quotidienne est en
ordre de bataille
donc on voudrait comprendre dans ce
dispositif comme on pourrait intervenir
une candidature éventuelle de nicolas
précisément ce n'est pas le sujet en
revanche ce qui est la question c'est
que louis effectivement l'ump se
réorganise oui l'ump a vécu une fin
d'année qui était une fin d'année
difficile que ce début d'année les
diables des derniers jours de l'année ce
début d'année sont soudés signaux
beaucoup plus positif et encourageant je
voulais rappelle premiers éléments des
rangs et des élections législatives
partielles qui ont toutes été gagnées
par l'ump
c'est donc un premier signal extrêmement
positive deuxième élément il y a une
volonté de rassemblement à la tête de
notre famille politique
session après la compétition entre
françois fillon et jean françois copé
l'ambiance non mais bah vous écouter
vous en juillet mais moi je vous dis pas
ce que je participe à toutes les
réunions par exemple ya une initiative
commune fillon juppé balladur pour des
primaires ouvertes à droite
donc est ce que ce serait compatible
avec une éventuelle d'un éventuel retour
de nicolas sarkozy j'arrive pas bien
écouté c'est très simple de votre
question est compliquée mais moi ma
réponse est simple pendant que vous le
dire et ma réponse est simple c'est
s'agissant de l'organisation des
primaires que en ce moment l'ump sur
laquelle on lui a fait en train de
réfléchir pour proposer des statuts de
manière à bâtir une formation dynamique
moderne et bien sûr les primaires je le
dis moi vous m'interrogez moi je dis je
suis pour qu'il y ait un système qui
soit le système le même pour tout le
monde
en clair je ne souhaite je ne demande
pas de système dérogatoire vous et votre
question était à compliquer dans sa
formulation simple dans sa réponse
simple celle de l'état devra se
soumettre de revenir le système
s'applique à tout un chacun s'était
passé mais dites moi on vous écoute vous
avez évoqué la situation très grave à
différents points de vue ce que selon
vous seul aujourd'hui à droite nicolas
sarkozy est à même d'assurer le
leadership de l'ump paris est ce qu'il
est mais d'abord on y connait ce pont là
me colle dit collaborer dans séraphine
n'a pas vocation ici à assumer un
leadership sur l'ump parce que parfois
on entend des déchets de leurs sourires
audience dépasse vous attendez ne
mènerait pas juger si je reste on sur
l'ump sur et organise nous allons avoir
de nouveau statut avec de nouvelles
règles avec un calendrier électoral avec
une direction qui est aujourd'hui une
direction très ouvert très paritaire et
chacun souligne aujourd'hui que les
choses se passent bien jean françois
copé l'a dit que régulièrement françois
fillon s'est exprimé il ya quelques
jours à la télévision et il a dit qu'il
était heureux de travailler dans un
climat qui était apaisée il ya même un
mode qualificatif mais qu'elle est
dans le même sens et donc c'est des
choses je vous lis les choses se passent
bien l'ump et devient chaque jour
davantage dans une nation incarnant
laura smet dans la baie à droite et du
sco relever les grands défis de la
france en crise est-ce qu'il faut un an
d'expérience donc est-ce que c'est
limité au chef de l'état
ou est-ce qu'on peut inclus à ce que
vous incluez par exemple françois fillon
dans ces hommes qui pourraient relever
les défis du futur à droite il y a il y
a à droite
de très nombreux talents de très
nombreuses expériences vous le site bien
sûr où jt françois fillon vous parlez de
jean françois copé
il y a aussi des personnalités sur le
départ c'est ce que bono dit oui tout le
monde n'a pas la même expérience
exactement ce qu'il ce qui n'est pas du
fait de ses différentes expériences
il y à une inégalité dans les
expériences plus de départ où est
l'égalité dans les expériences
donc au delà des conditions politiques
dits dont il ya des échéances
judiciaires le conseil constitutionnel
va statuer sur les comptes de campagne
de nicolas sarkozy
il ya les soupçons de financement de la
campagne de par la libye la ferme est en
cours est ce que vous craignez que ce
soit des obstacles à un retour en
politique nous écouter sur l'aspect
financier les comptes de campagne je ne
suis pas du tout un spécialiste
ce que je crois très honnêtement c'est
que quand on est élu pour cinq ans il
faut exercer son mandat pendant cinq ans
alors à titre personnel ça encore une
fois ça n'engage que moi je pense qu il
serait curieux qui est des règles qui
disent vous est élu pour cinq ans mais
vous pouvez président pour quatre ans
donc c'est ce que je pense ma foi envers
amélioré de décision chacun
naturellement la respectera pense compte
quand on a si on a choisi le quinquennat
c'est pour avoir un président en
activité pendant cinq ans pour le reste
vous évoquez une affaire pour laquelle
nicolas sarkozy est victime est victime
aujourd'hui vous avez parlé d'
instrumentalisation committee non j'ai
pas du tout parlé des somatisations j'ai
dit j'observe simplement c'est une
observation là aussi très personnel que
il ya un message affectif qui est
adressée à nicolas sarkozy est vraiment
le nomma ya un télescopage avec une
autre chose
ce que vous et vous qui par exemple sur
ce sujet il convient de rappeler que
nicolas sarkozy est aujourd'hui victime
et qu'il a d'ailleurs porté plainte pour
des peintres pas tout à fait les mêmes
choses voilà alors à l'ump on dit que
l'on va changer un peu de sujet on et
l'ump ont dit qu'il ne peut il n'y a
aucune alliance possible avec le front
national
pourtant on voit défiler le député fn
gilbert collard en côté d'eux des
députés ump
mais écoutez vous n'avez jamais
interrogés voient responsable du front
national dans votre merdier une
collusion entre aix et toi écoutez moi d
parfois et on attendait un espace en
plein air une manifestation sur un sujet
écoute et c'est pas parce que un
responsable du front national où
monsieur mélenchon disque au mois d'août
il doit faire beaucoup jouent à
considérer ça comme moi je fais c'est ce
qu'il choisit jouer donc j'ai les autres
j'ai pour mes convictions
vous avez le dpt collard ou un autre
responsable front national qui tient
solidairement la banderole saba vous
allez jouer des coudes ou pas vous devez
jouer des coudes eux en tout cas pas des
points ça c'est sûr les eaux de l'est je
dis moi simplement votre âge et quand
j'irai manifester
j'irai manifester avec mes amis et pour
des convictions me préoccupe pas de qui
à côté de van der sar 6 espaces mêmes
préoccupations sur le mariage à côté
sans problème
écouter pendant vous mais moi je sais
très bien ce que vous dites et moi je me
souviens d'une réunion j'avais organisé
dans ma région en auvergne avec les
ministres de l'intérieur et des sur les
questions migratoires c'était une
conférence européenne sur les questions
d'intégration
il ya une manifestation qui était
organisée par le parti socialiste arrive
et par parti socialiste à l'occasion de
cette manifestation du parti ciosi à
l'extrême gauche qui est venu mais
c'était autre chose est sûre mais ce
qu'ils attendent et ils sont venus ce
classique
jour ils sont venus casser ils sont
venus brûlé ils ont abîmé des vitrines
et l'ont bousculé les policiers vous est
étonné à l'époque beaucoup avaient fait
quelque chose avait interrogé les deux
poids deux mesures madame écoutez moi
bien y'a pas de quoi demain je vous le
dis les les responsables du parti
sioniste qui était en 15e manifestation
j'ai pas un dit j'ai pas pensé pour
autant il était devenu le fait de
demande de ne pas attendez je vous dise
tu resterais pas deux poids deux mesures
ce qui est valable pour les ailes
valable pour les autres si vous ça vous
et suscite pas des questions sur ces
sujets je vois pas pourquoi je me pose
non mais là on parle de l'actuelle crise
parce qu'il y avait par exemple
sénateurs bourgnac il avait le député
ollier tout près ils sont les idées du
front national a contesté la présence et
nous ont dit on n'en voulait pas on
était à table on était jeunes et vous
vous n'avez pas la maison et ils sont
partis ils ont peint des défilés pour
défendre leurs convictions ils ont été
gênés et moi quand j'irai des filles et
j'irai des fier pour mes convictions ne
me préoccupe pas de ce voix qui est à
côté ça m'est égal
jean ba pour mes convictions vous pensez
qu'il faut contenir le front national
néanmoins bien sûr mais parce que le
front national c'est bien sûr le front
national et ses d'accréditer l'idée
qu'il y aurait des solutions simples à
des problèmes compliqués ce qui n'est
pas le cas deuxième élément avec le
front national nous allons plusieurs
différences majeures
moi je puise je puise mon engagement
dans le gaullisme
eux ils puisent leur engagement dans
l'anti gaullisme c'est une différence
majeure deuxième différents proches pour
aider deuxième différence
nous n'avons pas un point commun en
matière de politique européenne pas un
point commun nous sommes en désaccord
sur tout voilà bouksim actionnariat
alors pour écrire un premier match et
pas question d'un accord par exemple
dans certaines de nos élections
municipales s'y est mis en doute en moi
question que l'objectif du front
national c'est pas de se lier ces deux
remplacés donc il m'a exemple à
marseille
pourquoi amorcé le parti n'avait dit que
si jean claude gaudin a échoué
c'était à cause du front national ça
c'est vrai à cause du froid pendant la
victoire est de françois hollande
elle est due au front national
l'athéisme du front national le front
national a appelé à faire barrage contre
nicolas sarkozy
donc la victoire fonctionne par nous
dire avec meetic mans elle est donc due
au fonds national oui vous avez raison
merci suivait pas les ferrington de cela
arrive maintenant ressorte fait avancer
enquêter sur le doubs de dieu que vous
formez avec nicolas sarkozy il ya près
de trente ans maintenant déjà et qui
aujourd'hui fait nouveau un oracle très
écouté par ses amis ils se connaissent
par coeur et se comprennent entre
nicolas sarkozy et brice hortefeux c'est
une amitié de près de 40 ans si des
lieutenants pour certains porte flingues
diront d'autres
brice hortefeux longtemps dans l'ombre
est désormais sur le devant de la scène
pour parler de son mentor depuis le 6
mai 2012 l'ancien chef de l'état restent
discrets sont plus fidèles alliés
fondent les amis de nicolas sarkozy et
distille les informations jugées utiles
dans les médias brice hortefeux porte
voix de nicolas sarkozy une affirmation
qui agace leurs proches notamment
patrick balkany
il est président de l'association des
amis de nicolas sarkozy ça peut bien
dire ce que ça veut dire
on défend le bilan on est proche du
président on souhaite ardemment
son retour points mais nous ne sommes
pas ses porte parole
leur histoire commence alors que brice
hortefeux à 18 ans il est immédiatement
séduit par nicolas sarkozy de trois ans
son aîné
il ne se sépareront plus leur parcours
seront indissociables
et aujourd'hui alors que nicolas sarkozy
remonte dans les sondages
charles pasqua proches des deux hommes
s'amusent de voir certains rivalisent et
d'amitié avec l'ancien président moi je
suis pas choqué que que beaucoup de gens
se disent les amis de nicolas sarkozy
très bien mais lui même je crois qu'il
est assez lucide et brisseau c&a les
vrais amis c'est plus que ça se passe
comme fram pour nicolas brice hortefeux
qui attise la flamme en attendant un
éventuel retour de nicolas sarkozy en
politique même si pour le moment la
consigne est de garder le silence
vous êtes d'accord avec lui la cour se
reforme un petit peu autour de nicolas
sarkozy elle est proportionnelle
finalement au sondage à la courbe des
sondages
écoutez franchement j'ai l'expérience de
la vie publique
j'ai vu beaucoup de choses mais julie
quoi sont un sarkozy l'est où l émail
bien sûr bg pas c'est pas le sentiment
je vous le dis très sincèrement c'est
pas le sentiment que j'ai quand on a
pris l'initiative de fonder cette
association parce que nous étions
évidemment triste déçu déçu
individuellement déçu collectivement et
déçu pour notre pays il ya eu un
mouvement en étant très vite très
spontané et vous l'avez vu la fin du
mois d'août j'ai déjà beaucoup de monde
alors notre rassemblement à nice avec
christian estrosi et c'était le climat
politique a beaucoup changé notamment à
droite mais aussi dans l'ensemble du
pays est ce que vous avez l'impression
que la personnalité le personnage de
nicolas sarkozy attirent de plus en plus
de monde à nouveau autour de lui je vous
le dis là aussi que je regardais les
études qui sont faites et ce qu'on me
dit on me dit on ne compte à ce qu'on me
dit en eau verte c'est notre pays dans
une situation très difficile en proie au
doute à l'incertitude lendemain des
inquiétudes
finalement ressent le besoin d'avoir un
chef et un cap et a incontestablement
nicolas sarkozy savait incarner ses
fonctions ce qui explique aussi certains
contrastes où j'avais que aujourd'hui
les douves dans ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure il n'a pas renoncé à la
politique finalement nicolas sarkozy en
tout cas il a renoncé à l'expression
publique puisque vous et il avait dit le
6 mai qu'il serait un français parmi les
français et il ne s'est pas exprimée ou
plus exactement il s'est exprimé à une
seule reprise
une seule ses inventions seule reprise
sur une question d'ordre international
parce qu'il était très profondément
choqués de l'inaction et du silence
savez y aurait beaucoup de choses à dire
bien sûr sur ses cinq années passées
mais je suis convaincu peut-être nos
compatriotes ne s'en sont pas rendu
compte totalement que la france pendant
ces cinq années a été perçu dans le
monde comme la championne des droits de
l'homme et c'était vrai en libye on
l'évoquait c'était vrai en côte d'ivoire
c était vrai en géorgie mais maintenant
elle est aujourd'hui mais bien sûr et
là aujourd'hui sans doute le sentiment
est un peu différent sarkozy n'a pas
renoncé à la vie politique
écoutez ça n'en voulait me faire
répondre nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui ne
s'exprime pas dans la vie publique
d'être d'être un peu le message et de
nicolas sarkozy sait ce que c'est un
rôle qui vous convient écoutez en tout
cas et une précision que vous me donnez
l'occasion d'apporter c'est que nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas de porte parole officiel
qu'il n'a pas de porte parole officieux
donc je ne suis ni l'un ni l'autre je
suis un de ses amis je le soutiens et je
pense qu'il a fait beaucoup beaucoup
pour notre pays peut-être aujourd'hui on
s'en rend davantage compte c'est ce qui
fait que certaines choses ne sonne comme
avant d'autres termes est-ce qu'il
ferait certaines choses différemment
c'est le pouvoir écouter comme on
n'évoque pas son retour au pouvoir des
juges je ne peux pas évoquer ces aspects
là je ne sais pas si c'était un piège
tonnes en tout cas je pense avoir évité
les fonctions de la caricature du
porte-flingues et c est ce que ça vous
convient ce que vous trouvez ça
confortable vous l'avait accompagné tout
au long de son parcours professionnel
j'ai été son collaborateur j'ai été
notamment son chef de cabinet lorsqu'il
était ministre du budget enfin l'ong
tout est relatif je suis parlementaire
au ministre depuis 14 15 ans donc ça
fait une part d'ombré relative enfin
peut-être mais pas le jour écoutez ou
moins à vitré on a tendance mais moi je
me suis engagé en politique pour des
convictions je pense assez solide
un certain nombre de valeurs humaines
qui sont ces notamment de la fidélité de
mon engagement et donc je revendique
pleinement cet engagement côté nicolas
sarkozy qui était effectivement constant
ou a donc annoncé vous à vos ambitions
politiques dont bien sûr le mot ambition
c'est évidemment un peu particulier mais
c'est vrai que moi je suis
je suis issu d'un territoire qui est
ouvert est un territoire extrêmement
difficile sur le plan politique sans
doute mon intérêt ma carrière
précisément puisque vous évoquez aurait
dû me conduire à un moment où je vais
choisir d'autres d'autres lieux à
renoncer à ce territoire et a tenté une
chance avec ailleurs c'est pas bon
c'était pas ma conception c'est pas mon
engagement et dont je me va dans un thé
un contexte effectivement difficile une
région j'ai 13 ans très à gauche mais
vous savez il n'est pas abandonnée au
bout de l'espérance il ya toujours le
succès vous avez été mises de manuel
valls
on a du mal parfois à voir quelles
différences lien entre la politique au
métal intérieur conduite par manuel
valls est celle menée par la droite
cependant il ya une différence très
simple que très clair c'est les
résultats ce sont les résultats
il n'y a absolument pas les mêmes
résultats sous nicolas sarkozy avec les
ministres de l'intérieur successifs qui
là qu'il a nommé est il y a eu une
baisse constante constante de la
délinquance globale constante
il n'y a pas eu une année soit qu'elles
n'y a pas eu de baisse et aujourd'hui
avec le gouvernement il y à une hausse
constante constante pas un mois sans
clause de la délinquance globale ne
subiront pas de politique attendait les
spectateurs d'avoir modifié le barreau
m'attendais pas à des chiffres des neuf
premiers éléments mois et s'agira là je
respecte ceux qui ont la responsabilité
et de conduire la politique de sécurité
dans notre pays et je ne mets pas en
tout si vous voulez me faire dire je ne
mets pas en doute la volonté de manuel
valls d'assurer la sécurité de l'eau
considère oui simplement ça ne marche
pas parce que vous dites querelle de
chiffres ou non il n'y a aucune querelle
il y a les chiffres qui sont là net brut
pas du tout personne ne les comptait ce
sont des chiffres qui sont des chiffres
qui s'entiche yvon public
eh bien ces chiffres m'ont coûté c'est
comme ça mais c'est pas le hasard qu'il
y a eu dix ans de baisse régulière de la
dea
un camps ce gros banc et qui nous en
sommes à dix mois de hausse régulière de
la délinquance globale dont il n'y a pas
les mêmes résultats
il y aujourd'hui une dérive des
statistiques de la délinquance qui
s'explique non pas par l'air du temps
qui s'explique non pas par le hasard qui
s'explique parce que c'est la
conséquence d'une politique il n'y a pas
la même politique menée hier et
aujourd'hui
et comme il ya une politique différente
pardon de vous lire les résultats sont
effectivement différent et manuel valls
a quand même un petit peu gêné à droite
puis ce qui est devenu la nouvelle cible
politique de l'ump depuis quelques
semaines est ce qu'il faut le
démythifier parce qu'il séduit trop
peut-être aussi à l'électorat de droite
écoutez moi c'est pas en ces termes
lâche sur ces sujets et je pense que ce
qui compte c'est la protection de la
société et je vous dis des erreurs qui
sont commises
première erreur si on me posait la
question première erreur c'est d'avoir
dit qu'on mettait fin à la politique du
résultat nous nous émettions en place et
nous le revendiquerons la politique du
résultat oui c'est stimulant
si vous on vous dit écoutez peu importe
vos résultats ça n'a strictement aucune
importance
franchement vous n'êtes pas stimulé
alors bien sûr peur des excès ici ou là
nous ont dit nous jugeons sur les
résultats j'ai réunissait les préfets
jeu réunissez les directeurs
départementaux de la sécurité publique
je réunissais les commandants de
groupement de gendarmerie
je disais oui vous serez jugés sur vos
résultats
là on dit non des résultats ça compte
pas premiers éléments et deuxièmement on
est en train par la garde des sceaux
madame taubira de qui et détricotent en
était le code pénal
donc naturellement ça a des conséquences
oui je ne veux pas vous demander de
donner deux référents de chimay quand
nous nous proposons de construire 20 mai
place de prison et que la guerre de
dessau dit il n'y aura pas de
construction de l'habitat de prison et
ben pardon vous dire ça veut dire que
ravin midi alain quand c'est pas très
intelligent ce que je dis mais au moins
ça mérite d'être cohérent durera vingt
mille délinquants qui seront donc pas
incarcéré il à votre avis quand les
délinquants sont pas incarcérées que
font-ils
ils vont uniquement égrainé des
chapelets non à mon avis faut autre
chose
brice hortefeux ya un rapport
parlementaire cette semaine qui condamne
la suppression des renseignements
généraux menée en 2008 donc sous nicolas
sarkozy
ça a été une erreur selon ce rapport
parlementaire oui j'ai entendu j'ai été
auditionné j'ai pas vu le rapport
parlementaire parce qu'il est très
les récents gt a été auditionné par la
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale puisque jean jacques urvoas
m'avait proposé de devenir m'exprimer
j'ai donné mon sentiment et je pense que
partagent pas cet avis je pense que
globalement le rassemblement des
services de renseignements c'est à dire
en était la fusion dst et les
renseignements généraux était positive
voilà alors après ça veut pas dire que
vous en évoquer la direction du
renseignement créé aujourd'hui de moyens
et les compétences très bas très bien
répartie avec il ya peut-être des
améliorations apportées mais je pense
que le principe de la fusion des
services de renseignements intérieurs à
donner plus de cohérence et moins de
rivalité après jean-louis borloo
abandonne aujourd'hui sa robe d'avocat
une question de transparentes pour
garder seulement son mandat de
parlementaire est ce que c'est une bonne
chose selon vous de précéder ainsi les
textes qui vont être présenté demain en
conseil des ministres c'est une décision
personnelle ou l'accord non pas sur le
principe je suis très hostile à cela
très hostile sur le principe hostile et
je le dis la ficelle est un peu grosse
en août entre nous bassiner avec tout
tout tout tout ces mesures comme ça il
ya une réalité très simple chaves et
c'est venu du fait qu'il y avait un mini
chargée de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale qui précisément et évadé
procéder à des évasions fiscales c'est
parti de ça et on est en train d'essayer
de noyer tout ça tout d'un tout petit
chaudron
je vous donne je vous donne un exemple
très simple là ce que vous évoquez c'est
la situation des avocats au local des
avocats avec le réseau met évidemment
évident entre par exemple deux dossiers
privés qu'on fait la loi
savoir se retirer si l'inconscient je
suis très heureux pour vous apprendre
quelque chose et finiront peut-être que
je suis là pour ça donc c'est très
simple l'histoire des avocats avocat
combien en at il aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il y en a trente huit 38
est ce que c'est une explosion
l'inflation ça devient un fléau terrible
aurait coûté au moment des gouvernements
de gauche sous le cartel des soul cartel
des gauches en 1924 il y avait cent
trente huit avocats ou 134 avocat 134 au
moment du front populaire
gouvernement de gauche il avait attendu
que tu attendais tout domaine j'étais
bien sûr je vais venir il y avait 100
avocats donc alors n'essayons pas
d'expliquer que tout d'un coup on
découvre le fil à couper le beurre c'est
bien mais surtout la réalité c'est que
c'est déjà prévu par l'article du code
électoral l'article 149 monsieur
grossiord la compatibilité lisais je
dirai ce que vous en pensez
c'est sa compatibilité sont bien
respectés merci bonsoir à tous et à très
vite
qui représentera l'ump dans la course à
la mairie de paris
pierre yves bournazel nathalie kosciusko
morizet jean françois legaret franck
marlin pour celle battue eux ils
débattront pour les premières fois sur
public sénat samedi à 14 heures avec
france 3 ile-de-france dispositions sont
prises comme vous le savez pour que cela
n'ait aucun inconvénient d'aucune sorte
pour les chères populations de la
polynésie dans les années 60 la
polynésie est devenu le champ
d'expérimentation des essais nucléaires
français en 30 ans 193 expérimentation
aériennes et souterraines au lieu sur
ces atolls quelles conséquences sur la
santé et sur l'environnement
pour me tourner la page que tout soit
propre touche mclean et qu'on n'ait plus
à revenir dessus c'est tout essai
nucléaire
un héritage sans fin samedi à 22 heures
sur public sénat
tablettes smartphones internet mobile le
numérique est partout et même dans
l'esprit de françois hollande c'est le
quatrième engagement de son programme
présidentiel
une ambition numérique qui passe par
l'installation du réseau très haut débit
en france le réseau thd 50% du
territoire couvert dans 5 ans 100 % dans
dix ans une révolution technologique
pour soigner la fracture numérique
car aujourd'hui en france le réseau
internet connaît des faiblesses la
france est en train de poindre un retard
considérable par rapport au reste du
monde et même à l'intérieur de la zone
européenne par rapport aux peuples de
l'est nous sommes en train de prendre du
recul
aux côtés de son collègue ump pierre
hérisson
le sénateur yves rome s'est vu confier
une mission d'information par le sénat
fixer les conditions de cette
numérisation du territoire le très haut
débit une priorité un élément
indispensable pour bien vivre dans les
territoires au même titre que l'eau ou
l'électricité mais aussi une révolution
économique la fibre peut redonner de
l'attractivité à la france relancer la
compétitivité
il faut aller prévu à la vitesse de la
lumière à la vitesse de la fibre optique
le très haut débit par la fibre c'est
une aubaine pour un secteur celui des
entreprises
le e-commerce le commerce sur internet
est en plein boom comme ici dans l'oise
chez alfa direct service le numéro un de
la logistique en e-commerce
après votre shopping sur internet c'est
ici que vos commandes sont traitées
emballé et expédié c'est ici qu'arrivent
la fibre optique qui a changé en fait le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise et qui
nous a permis de recueillir de plus en
plus de commerçants et de gérer de plus
en plus de commandes par jour et pour se
rendre compte de l'impact du thd sur les
communications de l'entreprise visite du
sénateur rome ici le volume de données
et de plus en plus importants grâce à la
fibre
le chiffre d'affaires d'adp et s a
triplé la fibre optique nous a permis de
développer notre activité et de
développer nos process pour gérer de
plus en plus de commandes par heure
et de la meilleure façon également pour
les employés et de traiter le la
commande le plus simplement possible
la fibre optique et l'optimisation des
process en interne nous permet
aujourd'hui de gérer plus de 9000 qu'aux
membres par heure avant la fibre c'était
100 commandes par jour
une véritable révolution et ce n'est pas
le numéro un de la vente en ligne de
chaussures qui dira le contraire
le site spécialisé a trouvé chez ads une
efficacité pour ses clients une rapidité
d'exécution incluant sarenza peut
commander jusqu'à 15 heures et il
recevra son colis le lendemain matin
avec la fibre et avec l'ensemble des
fonctionnalités que l'on met en place et
des process que l'on met en place au
niveau de nos entrepôts on est capable
aujourd'hui de concurrencer les plus
gros sites e-commerce temps du monde en
termes de logistique très haut débit
fibre optique qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un fil de verre très fin
enveloppé dans une gaine de protection
sa capacité véhicule est un signal
lumineux à la vitesse de la lumière
la différence avec les anciens câble
type adsl c'est le débit 100 fois plus
élevés sur des milliers de kilomètres
aujourd'hui en france on compte deux
cent cinquante mille abonnés à la fibre
optique
quand certains pays ont déjà achevé
leurs déploiements et pour comprendre
les enjeux au sénat yves rome reçoit les
acteurs de la filière
aujourd'hui il auditionne les fabricants
et installateurs de fibres on voit très
bien développement du des réseaux fibre
optique et infrastructures à fibre
optique et les services associés des
services très haut débit associés comme
un enjeu équivalent à celui
d'électrification de pays au début du
20e siècle
compario on fabrique des câbles
électriques on a un bon parallèle devant
nous
on voit très bien comment se sont
structurés les réseaux électriques dans
les 50 dernières années et comment
devrait se structurer les réseaux à
fibre optique de selon ces industriels
cette technologie est indispensable dans
chaque foyer français
quand vous avez la fibre chez vous c'est
mon cas vous voyez pourquoi vous avez
besoin tout simplement s'arrêter vous
vous arrêtez de vous disputer avec vos
enfants etc pour savoir qui trafiquent
on verra bon ça diraient que c'est le
foot
le petit bout de la lorgnette c'est
celle c'est le sait la vision déjà
actuelle mais alors demain on n'en parle
même pas aujourd'hui dans le monde juste
derrière les leaders japonais et
américains en matière de fabrication
les français sont depuis longtemps près
et il est vrai qu'en france je vais
aujourd'hui c'était une ancienne usine
alcatel